hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
what we predicted was gonna happen
is happening we said this was gonna
happen years ago maybe even 10 years ago
and now it's happening what am i talking
about
stacy that's a good question well you
might have to go back and check
10 years of kaiser reports because we of
course did say this
long ago whereas over on the other
financial media
they were always uh just apologists for
the banks now the banks have come around
our way of seeing things and we
warned you first morgan stanley
cryptocurrencies here to stay a serious
asset class bitcoin making progress
to replace dollar so
this is a pretty major bank saying that
bitcoin is actually
on target to replace the dollar
as we alone told you first none
of the u.s cable news ever told you this
right and you can see it developing
every day in real time
as the market cap of bitcoin now pushing
a trillion dollars remember we first
started
recommending bitcoin to our audience
when the market cap was under
two million dollars when it was less
than a dollar yeah it was like under 10
million dollars yeah
sort of thing it was back in 2011. and
now the market cap's pushing a trillion
it's already i think the fifth or sixth
biggest currency
uh i believe it recently overtook the
swiss franc in terms of market cap and
size in the global market
it's uh getting close now about 50 or so
overtaking silver so the global silver
markets approximately just under 2
trillion so
certainly within a few months bitcoin
will be vaulting over silver
it's on its way in my believe in 2021 to
get halfway or
so against the market capitalization of
gold that it would be
4 trillion on its way to 10 trillion and
then you know once it gets past gold
there's only
the dollar is left and the thing about
bitcoin is that it is the apex predator
it is the shark in an ocean
full of goldfish and or plankton
and which is the us dollar they print a
lot of
dollars but they're not particularly
robust
and they are going to be decimated as
bitcoin
dominates and becomes the global world
reserve currency as we predicted so
morgan stanley now is finally waking up
to this
right i might add that stacy herbert
here i was on stansberry research's uh
podcast their video podcast by daniella
camboni
and i said that bitcoin was the fastest
horse in the race
and that gold was the best looking horse
at the glue factory he was heading to
the glue factory i saw that and all
these gold bugs were triggered and i was
gonna say
frank geistra who is a multi-billionaire
uh canadian goldbug did go on to twitter
to slander me and call me
and say that was the dumbest thing he
ever heard but here
again you know maybe he might take it
better coming from morgan stanley morgan
stanley's a head of emerging markets and
chief global strategist
reicher sharma published a report
entitled why crypto was coming out of
the shadows on the morgan stanley
website last week quote despite the
jitters natural and a global pandemic
cryptocurrencies are rapidly gaining
popular support as
alternatives to gold i.e a store of
value he said
and the dollar as a means of payment the
strategist
elaborated we see fundamental reasons to
believe that regardless of where the
price of bitcoin goes
next cryptocurrencies are here to stay
as a serious
asset class so he's saying it's
displacing the dollar
as a means of payment and gold as a
store of value
so these this is what we've been saying
like the bitcoin
is a black hole that's sucking in all
these markets is stuck in store of value
it's
sucking in means of exchange many of the
bitcoin debates that you see going on
between early
bitcoin proponents was always like no we
only want it to be a means of exchange
do not let it be a store of value like
you can stop the market you can stop
participants in the market
from using your your money as anything
that they want to use it as what's
remarkable is that
oh many years ago frederick hayek was
interviewed and said
money was a technology that 100 years
old many hundreds of years old
and as long as governments controlled
money there could be no advances in
money
yeah along comes bitcoin it separates
government from money
there's not no government can touch
bitcoin
they're completely divided and divorced
and as hayek predicted if you gave
people
hard money like bitcoin to transact
without the interference of government
it would be an economic global boom a
renaissance
and he was absolutely correct well
indeed
max because if you look at what also
this morgan stanley strategist says and
this
he in particular identifies this
distrust
of money printer gober of the
governments just again
as max and i here on kai's report have
been right for a decade now
whereas the cable news got it wrong over
and over
remember all they did was ever report
what the government at that time was
saying like
remember there used to be a narrative
that it was really bad and it was just
drug runners and
and bad guys using it that was back in
2013 14
15. like we always identified what was
what was the future for this whole
monetary system and
now morgan stanley's agreeing sharma
explained that one reason
for the growth in it is growing distrust
in fiat currencies
thanks to massive money printing by
central banks
it's been caused by the money printing
by central banks
it's not being caused by bitcoin it's
not being caused by us
it's not being caused by people who
point out this
issue that is arising the cantillion air
effect
causing unrest causing distrust causing
anger at the injustice of some people
getting free money
from the fed or the treasury and most
others
not so it's it's morgan stanley points
out as we've been saying is not us
pointing it out it's the fact that the
fed and the money printing going on
is the one is that's the issue at heart
here
that's why we've destroyed our set so
many times with max
blowing that money gun all over the
place right yeah well
look it says right there in the genesis
block of january 3rd 2009
uh chancellor on brink of second bailout
for banks
that should have been the hint that this
was here to
to put an end to the central banks and
now here we are in 2021 and now morgan
stanley
is quoting essentially the genesis block
of bitcoin
and then you know a lot of the
mainstream media quote all these
um naysayers of bitcoin who are gold
bugs themselves
and here's what morgan stanley says
again backing exactly what kaiser report
has told you
for years another reason
is generational as young people
view cryptocurrency as an improvement
over metal coins he continued quote
the worst knock on cryptocurrency as a
store of value is its volatility
that's naseem telev recently said that
but
unflinching demand from millennials
has helped lower the volatility of
bitcoin
even during the pandemic right i mean
the question is do you accept fiat money
where the volatility is zero but the
loss of
purchasing power is guaranteed
or would you prefer bitcoin where there
is volatility
but the gain in purchasing power is
guaranteed
those are your two options i might add
like
we had a personal situation with the
volatility of the us dollar in that when
we made a film for al jazeera english
back in 2005 i think it was her six
right when they started their launch
week
we made a film called the death of the
dollar and we were paid in dollars our
budget was
well between the one month of signing it
and the six weeks later of delivering
and then getting paid
um the dollar crashed by 20 percent so
we lost money because
our expenses were all in euros and
pounds and we were like well that was a
dumb move to make a film called death of
the dollar and get paid in dollars
yeah it's ironic we learned our lesson
for sure we
watched that film in great detail trying
to figure out how do we end up
on the short end of that deal what was
up with us
so also again continuing with the
millennials who we
identified as they they would be happy
to accept bitcoin as a store of value
much better than gold well he says
the strategist added that this age group
believes the open source software behind
bitcoin
makes it more transparent transferable
and trustworthy than paper printed by
governments
he emphasized that this crypto
confidence may reach even deeper
in emerging markets where distrust and
centralized authorities
run high governments have been slow to
recognize this evolution
bitcoin is also starting to make
progress on its ambition to replace the
dollar
as a medium of exchange this also
highlights uh
a paradox that i have trouble figuring
out and that is that those who are
anti-bitcoin many times identify as
libertarian what morgan stanley is
saying here quite clearly
is that bitcoin is um a libertarian's
dream
you know it's effectively saying that
you are getting
you are defunding the government in
effect
and that would be an appealing pitch to
somebody who
calls themselves a libertarian but for
some reason these
so-called libertarians they seem to
really side with what are called
statists
and and they take a position against
bitcoin so they're confused both
monetarily they don't seem to understand
what money is
and they're confused politically they
don't understand what side of the
political aisle they stand on
and i guess the most there's some
obvious examples of that well
okay the underlying issue here is money
printing money printer
money printer chancellor and bring a
second bailout from banks
who owns the most gold in the world
other than the women of india
it's the central banks so here you're
the you know these gold bugs jumped on
the whole crash of the financial system
buy our bags buy some gold from us buy
some gold from me
peter schiff the underlying flaw
is that the governments and central
banks all own most of it
so here they're identifying the kids see
that
governments can not control it they
don't own it
you know some governments own bits of it
right but they they can't control it as
if they point out also it's transparent
transferable and trustworthy
transferable try transferring a bar of
gold right
we can transact in unconfiscatable
uncensorable money when nobody can stop
us because we're
protected by this encrypted shield
called the bitcoin protocol that's
impenetrable and nobody can
stop us and no and governments have
flapped their gums a lot and suggested
oh we're against it
but none of them can stop it and i think
well eventually one of these governments
according to the game theory
is going to say you know what enough is
enough we're going to start putting it
on our balance sheet here in whatever
country that might be
and then every other country will do
exactly the same thing and the price of
course will go
500 600 000 a million dollars of bitcoin
and
max and stacy will be once again 100
right
it's like arguing standing in front of
the mona lisa and arguing
this painting is horrible why are you
people coming to see this why are you
flocking to see it it's like
it's it's stood the test of a thousand
years it's been like 700 years being the
best painting ever
like everybody wants to see it it's
mesmerizing nobody can maybe explain it
but it's mesmerizing so that's the thing
about bitcoin it is just the best money
because all value is subjective and and
the new generation
sees it as the best money so it's it is
right the millennials are the biggest
generation ever
they see it as money therefore it is
money oh and by the way it is
unconfiscatable and sensorable and no
government can stop it
wow okay then i guess it's going a lot
higher because it has to replace
gold it has to replace the us dollar the
total addressable market
tam for bitcoin is 300 trillion dollars
it's now at 1 trillion it's got a 300
x path to go from here
own it or you know
have fun staying poor all right we're
going to take a break
when we come back much more don't go
away
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to return
to our conversation with entrepreneur
and businessman dan
collins dan welcome back hey max
all righty stan druckenmiller
multi-billion dollar hedge fund manager
hasn't had it down year since 1981. he's
now very
very short the dollar and he's very long
asia
including china he notes that the u.s is
still locked down
and expanded money supply 25 annually
while china hasn't had to do this what's
your analysis of the pandemic and
post-pandemic situation dan
well the u.s dollar we're clearly
getting towards a new sterling crisis
you know if people remember the sterling
crisis of the 70s
70s the british prom probably lost 75
percent of its value
budgets started getting cut industries
closed people lost faith in the pound
and
everything went to the dollar we're kind
of in that transition phase
now the doll the printing of the dollar
you're seeing it's mathematical we're
reaching the end game here
10 trillion last year another 10
trillion is going to happen this year
the printing can't stop if the printing
stops the whole house of cards collapses
so
there's no out there's no road map
outside for the united states economy
the way it's built today
other than money printing so i think
what he's getting at there is
you know and our money printing is based
off a
unreal economy our manufacturers our
manufacturing is gone our
infrastructure crumbled you know our
economy is not is built basically on a
house of cards and all this money
printing is going to
cause a transition to china and the rmb
i think
right now here's a headline to consider
uh china and swift are partnering to
take a digital currency global
uh we are heading to a post dollar
settlement layer world it seems dan
uh how is asia how is this going to
impact asia
so as you know max we uh the us has one
of our exorbitant privileges is to print
dollars and and get goods for it we get
saudi oil we get
chinese manufactured goods that
privilege is ending we've used that
we've weaponized the swift system
china knows this russia knows this the
rest of the world is even the europeans
aren't happy about it
and we're going to lose that privilege
we just keep printing money and getting
goods for it they've been working for
years now
to go around this system what was just
announced as you mentioned
the swift is partnering with china on
the digital yen
china as we've talked before is 50x the
number of mobile payments i mean if you
take
cash in china and try to give it to
somebody at the cash register they're
going to look at you like you're crazy
we don't have cash change to give you so
there
everything's been mobile payments now
china's taking the next leap forward
they're doing the digital u.n
it's already been launched in four or
five cities atms are out in the cities
people are getting drops of blockchain
based digital yen so that they can
test it out the big corporate china is
right behind it jd alibaba's everyone's
accepting digital yen now
this is going to be china's digital
currency and um
if you want a free ecosystem it's going
to be the bitcoin ecosystem
the dollar we have yet to really move
fast enough on the digital dollar
so the whole point of this on these
blockchain type currencies is the lower
transactions get the velocity of money
moving
and over here in the u.s we're still
writing checks and that's where the
bitcoin ecosystem has moved in to try to
create
a digital currency system and i think
what we're going to see going forward is
that digital yen is going to link up
internationally to bitcoin
and the us dollar will have to be on a
bitcoin system
and we'll see if a digital dollar ever
gets done at this point
we're not good at getting anything done
so i don't see it happening but uh yeah
that's what's what's going on with the
digital yen
right you mentioned an interesting point
there the central bank digital
currencies
are in vogue all over the world china's
coming out with theirs
uh but you do mention that you believe
it's going to migrate to
a bitcoin ecosystem bitcoin would be the
base layer it would be the
the the collateral layer if you will uh
because of its uh incredibly secure
uh nature and um the fact that it's
becoming kind of a global
standard so um that's an interesting
point i mean
um they of course china is also
very close strategically with uh
iran and russia do you see that
spreading into
into those areas and by the way
and do you see that spreading into those
areas and at the same time can you give
an update on the belt and road
initiative
sure absolutely we're we're coming into
a world with two geopolitical blocks
it's basically us and western europe
and then again maybe south america
against everyone else it'll be china
russia iran turkey
basically a complete eurasian bloc and
geopolitically we're coming up against
that
china is already you know moving 5g
electrical grids
that also africa is going to be in that
core the digital yen is designed to go
around the u.s dollar system i mean
china could start sending digital yen to
the
central bank of nigeria central bank of
tanzania wherever and so that's going to
combine with the one belt one road
so one belt one road is all about
building out ports and electrical grids
and roads
and building up the economies of mostly
the you know these
countries that have been left behind
economically where some simple
infrastructure
development greatly improves their
economy you know it's shrinking travel
times and getting marked goods to market
and things like that
but absolutely i think eventually we're
going to see everyone have a digital
currency
it's going to have to combine
internationally somewhere and it's not
going to be an sdr
no one's going to trust the imf it'll be
a bitcoin layer
but the interesting thing will be you're
not printing new bitcoins you're only
printing the new digital currencies
so they'll have digital currencies but
they'll continue to print it they'll
continue to expand that supply base
so um you're going to have a bitcoin
ecosystem and you'll have national
digital currency
ecosystems right well let's uh let's
talk about some other high-level
skullduggery we can't mention uh any
kind of democratic connection to
any chinese scandals of course because
this show goes on youtube and
youtube is very sensitive about that and
they're very protective of
those folks so but we can slam
republicans so uh talk about the mitch
mcconnell
chinese elite scandal dan yeah mitch
uh his his wife is a uh their father
owns a
very large shipping company that uh
there's china based they're very
integrated with the top ccp leadership
they've gotten hundreds of millions of
dollars in contracts
for sisters on the board of director of
the bank of china
so they're very very deep connections in
very high places
within those families right so uh there
is a bit of a kerfuffle out there
students are being deported chinese
students and
um because there's a lot of paranoia now
between the two countries
so is this uh overblown overreaction was
there naivete
involved break it down is america
got a chinese student spy problem dan
well i i think it's a it's a bad policy
in general so we have you know
hundreds of thousands of china we did
pre-covet have hundreds of thousands of
chinese students here in the united
states
all paying international fees which are
you know
two times three times more than
americans pay um
and you know as you said 99.9 percent of
them there's
there's not an issue there and we have
cultural
soft power when they come over here they
love it a lot of them learn to love the
us
they become culturally close to us we
understand each other
and it's not just them coming here we we
go over there my first
time in china i was an exchange student
at chiang wang university which is like
the mit of china
so this kind of cross-cultural exchange
is a good thing
with that being said we are a little bit
naive and sometimes and we let chinese
uh students into very sensitive areas
where they were they probably shouldn't
be
um so you know there's reasons to uh
be careful of it but you can't throw the
baby with the bathwater here and
um be completely isolated from from
china it
just doesn't make sense to what degree
do you think that that has had
in swinging the economic pendulum away
from the u.s toward china
well it's uh yeah i mean it's hard to
say i mean there's nothing that china
doesn't know
basically i mean there are so many
people here in so many sensitive
positions
um if you go you know most of the phds
we graduate are from china or india
so we stopped producing a lot of phd
candidates and things like mathematics
and physics you know we basically
import students for those programs so um
they're everywhere in high sensitive
areas um
and i think only the last year or so
that u.s
fbi and places like this are starting to
look at this china has the confucius
institutes
that were set up at most campuses in the
united states united states
is putting in uh action against those
interesting quan
uh issue that uh us will have to deal
with going forward
right meanwhile i don't see uh many
russian students here but
okay that's another story hey uh so the
u.s dollar turns uh 50 in august
does it live uh all the way to that 50th
uh
anniversary uh what what are china's
plans post dollar
uh post dollar i think um you know it's
free
right now the united states is a free
rider on the global trade system right
we print stuff and we get stuff
for free just by printing our money
that's going to end we will go through a
sterling crisis like britain had in the
70s
the dollar will be around the question
is what will be the value you know we
could
if you look at our export profile you
know if you look at our economic profile
and you look at our industrial capacity
we are in for a very large drop in
living standards
probably to the tune of 50 to 75 and
you're seeing that already you're seeing
the tent cities pop up everywhere
it's happening in slow motion as long as
the money printing keeps going
exponential
it slows that collapse down but um
eventually it catches up to us right the
living standards for a while it was
hidden because although
jobs were being exported to china the
price of stuff was dropping faster than
the wages were
dropping so people were able to afford
high screen tvs and close
cheap clothes and so that living
standards were
not noticeably collapsing but now
due to the ravages of what we must now
call
inflation there's inflation in the
system commodities are entering into a
secular bull market
prices are starting to actually go up in
a meaningful way
so now the pendulum swings the other way
so that drop in living standard suddenly
becomes
noticeable and you're seeing that really
all over the us
dan absolutely
labor rates in china this year are up 25
percent a lot of that's due to covid
but we are about to see the pendulum
swing absolutely where instead of 20
years of
exporting cheaper and cheaper products
here we're going to get 10 to 20 years
of more and more expensive products
and it's going to hit everybody in the
living standards i see it every week
everything's going up five percent a
month copper is at all
eight year high uh you know whether it's
scrap steel pig iron
any type of chemical finished goods
everyone's putting in price increases
across the board
and we're going to have it's almost a
supply chain bottleneck
inflation type of economy everybody's
gonna have to gear up for and get ready
to survive in
right so the semiconductors is just a
canary in the coal coal mine i mean it's
gonna
impact everything across the board
you're gonna see supply gaps
and price increases and florida though
it seems like a bright spot in the
in the nation at least they're
attracting some brilliant people like
yourself
and maybe they can lead this country
back to greatness dan collins thanks for
being on the kaiser report
thanks a lot max all right that's going
to do it for this edition of kaiser
report with me max kaiser and stacey
herbert
i want to thank our guest dan collins
until next time bye y'all
[Music]
you